真の幸福の道 一切の物事に執着を捨てることで
生きることを choice することで
真の幸福が現れる それで世の中は苦しみ
引っ越しすれば幸せですよと聞いたら
あんたどこまで引っ越しするのかと
苦しみから苦しみに引っ越しするのは幸せですよ
そうすると無限に引っ越しなくちゃいけないんです
どこへ引っ越したっても苦しみだから
だからそれが幸福の道ではありません
幸福の道は この執着するところにあるんです
生きることを choice するところにあるんです
安らぎの順番では この順番があります
ただ さっさと順番変えて終わります
眼耳鼻舌身の対象に依存することを極力控えてみる
眼耳鼻舌身に依存することは極力控える
必要なところで終わった方がいいんです
それはまあ 経典では何のこともなく
もう欲から離れてなんだらかんたら書いてるところですけど
感覚の苦が減ります 結構減りますよ
苦しみ ストレスも疲れもなくなります
感覚にこの激しい波動が振動ないんだから
ストレスもないし あの心臓的な波もなくなっていくんですよ
結構 思考妄想を制御する
次に二次的な苦しみ 一次的な苦しみをまあ極力控える
それは消すことは不可能です
現実だから しかし 二次的な苦しみに次に挑戦する
思考妄想を制御する 二次的な苦が消えていきます
巨大なスケールで安らぎを経験する
そうするとすごい安らぎを経験するんです
極限に弱い心は依存することはやめません
我々の心は極限に弱い
だから俗世間は娑婆世界ほど楽しい世界ないでしょと勘違いしている
依存したいんですよ 心が弱いんですよ
心を徐々に強くするんです
それで前も説明したでしょうね
幸せを感じたければ もうむちゃくちゃ弱い心を持ってくださいと
そうすると何にでも感動できるんだよと
でもそこは付け加えますけど
だから 弱い心で物に依存することは幸せじゃありません
その代わりに心を強くするんです
依存しない心にするんです
依存が減るたびに安らぎ
だと心は経験する この心の依存が減れば減るほど安らぎだなと感じるんです
無常の情報の流れが自分に無常の感覚の流れを作っているということを発見する
次の順番 まず心を統一して
妄想も控えて安らぎを感じてほしい
それから感覚が触れては消えていること
触れては消えていることが見えてくるんです
流れやと 安らぎないとこれ見えてこないんですよ
私は感覚の流れに対して使用する単なる言葉で
これ間違ってます 何の実体もないのだと発見する
何にではなくて 何の実体もありませんと
私はという このこれは鍵かっこに入れてますよ
私は私はいつでも主語を使っているでしょう
これがただの言葉ですよと
実体ないんだと 感覚の流れだよと
例えば荒川というために荒川のどんな水でしょうかと聞くと
そんなのはないでしょう
ただの水ですからね 執着不可能な感覚に執着するから
限りのない苦しみとゴールのない幸福の探求が行っていたことを発見する
次に何に発見するか よくバカなことをやっていたんだと発見します
執着不可能ですよ なのに執着していたっていう
だから苦しんでいたんだ
なんてバカかと 自分が
ヴィパッサナー瞑想をやっている人々は
もう最終段階になってくると
このアホなことどこまでやっているのかと
この繊細することって
なんてバカかと こんな執着
よく執着したもんだなと
すぐすぐ消える感覚に
私がいないんじゃないかという気分になります
心から執着が消え 完全な安らぎに達する
執着が消えることも 自我が消えることも同じことで
それで完全な安らぎということを心は経験するのです
だから心はすごく強いんです
それから裏にある深層の波が
これはきれいさっぱり消えるんです
しかし 上の波があるんです
悟っても誰かに殴られると痛いんですよ
それでその説明 覚者の苦
体に触れるものによって
一時的な苦も楽も現れるんです
たとえお釈迦様であっても
蚊に刺されると痛いんです
暑い時はお釈迦様も暑い暑いと言って川に入ったりとか
それで森の中に入ったりして
それでも夏が長くて もうお釈迦様ほとんど寝られませんでしたけど
まあ昼寝でもしようかなとか
苦しい やっぱり苦しいんです
一時的な苦しみはあったんです
苦いものは覚者が覚者食べても
俗人が食べても苦いんです
覚者は 覚者は苦い味だと知って終わるんです
あ 苦い味だなと 感覚も食べるものも無常だと知る
それで悟った人 そこ人は 1次の苦から 2次の苦も 3次の苦も作る悪循環に突入する
苦いものを食べた一般人が
あー嫌だ こんなの私はすごく食べたくない
なんで食べなくちゃいけないんで
いろいろ妄想するんだから
もっと美味しいものはないんでしょうかとか
この人わざと苦いもの作ってくれたんではないかとかね
人間にそんなことしていいのかどうか
あんた料理下手ではない？いろんな苦しみ作るんですよ
2次的な苦しみも  3次的な苦しみも
皆様 一般的な仏教の世界では
一の一の矢と二の矢の話を聞いているでしょう
今度は 3番目の山ありますけど
今日はそれを紹介したんです
ですから まあ終了 我々はどうしましょう
我々は自分の自由をね
確保しましょうということで
情報によって心が喜んだり沈んだりすると自由はありません
外から入る情報は私たちの心を支配しているんです
情けないんですよ 自分自分と偉そうなこと言ったっても
情報に支配されているんです
自分の心は他人の他のものの勝手なんです
自分の心が他人の勝手ですよ
それでいいんですかね
他人に何でもできますよ
自分の心に対して怒らせることも
楽しませることも やりたい放題
我々はなんか猫に捕まったネズミのような生き方していますよ
自由はないんです それは情報に依存することなんです
奴隷になって惨めに生きているんです
ですから 俗人の生き方は抜群な幸福な生き方じゃないんです
ビル・ゲイツさんであろうが
ブッシュ大統領であろうが
誰であろうが 奴隷の奴隷なんですよ
ね いじめに生きているだけ
自由がないんです 眼耳鼻舌身意に色
色声香味触法が必ず絶えず衝突する
それはもうどうしようもない
しかし 外の情報によって心が動揺しないようにと気をつけることが
自由を確保する唯一唯一の道です
音が触れても まあ気にしないことにするぞと
食べたものはちょこっとまずくても
まあ気にしないことにして
栄養あるんだから じゃあ食べるそうとかね
人がいろんな嫌なことを言っても
まあ音ですから まあいいんでしょうということで
心の自由を増す増すんですよ
例えば人が私を怒鳴る
その人の狙いがわかるでしょ
私を怒らせたいんです
侮辱したいんです こちら気にしなきゃ誰の勝ち？こちらの勝ちでしょう
あなたみたいな人間はもうとんでもないとか
あれこれと言ってもね
もうなんて失礼な人でしょうかとかね
別に あ そう なるほど で終わっちゃったらどうですかね
誰が勝ってますかね 自分が勝ってますよ
こちらなんてそんなことを言うのかとか
そんなこと言ったって
もうこれはこうであれでとか攻撃しちゃうと負けてます
逆も同じですよ なんてすごい人ですかね
あなたに会うことができて
私は大変幸せです 言われるとこっちが舞い上がっちゃうでしょうに
負けてます 全部自由がなくなるんです
そういうことで気づくんです
情報に操れないように
心動揺させない人は 外の世界を明確にする賢者なのです
面白いことあるんですよ
人が言うことは全然受け入れないで
音だけにすると 面白いことに
その人は何を感じているのか
どんな狙いでいるのか
どんなことが喋っているのか
それを上手に喋っているのか下手なのか
言ってることは順番正しいのかないのか
そこまでわかるんです
しかし 全然怒ってないんです
受け入れてもないんで
だから人の話を受け入れないことで馬鹿になることと逆なんです
相手がカンカン怒って怒鳴っているのに
あのね ちょっと文法間違い
それはそうじゃない これでしょうと教えてあげれば
私はよくやりますよ もうあんた言ってること
ちょっと理屈が成り立ってないから
これでこれでこうだと言ったらこうこうなるんだけど
あんた言ったらこれでこれでこうなるっていうことで
本人はどうしようもなくなっちゃうんです
せっかくこちらは怒鳴っているのに
別なこと言ってます だから聞き入れないと
ちゃんと聞いたり見たりするんですよ
主観的な世界がなければ全部見えるんです
で 終わりです はい まあ結構時間になりましたけど
ありがとうございます